[Music]
on this Sunday night a deadly Crash
Landing dozens killed in Nepal's worst
air disaster in decades what I'm seeing
would be consistent with derald
economics store the historic danger
flying in the Himalayas
rescues from the rubble searching for
survivors after a Bomb Blast through an
apartment Block in Ukraine the
lieutenant governor who tore down
barriers The Province and the country
have been changed because of his
determination remembering David only a
champion for disability Justice
global national with para Nasser
good evening thank you for joining us a
plane ride full of passengers looking to
take in the beauty of the Himalayan
Mountains ended in tragedy in Nepal this
morning local time hundreds of Rescuers
from the Army and Navy descended to the
area to search for survivors but the
hope of finding anyone from Yeti flight
691 is fading search efforts came to a
halt as evening fell there
the plane carrying 72 on board plummeted
into a Gorge surrounded by treacherous
Terrain
the yeti Airlines twin propeller plane
took off from the capital Kathmandu on
Sunday morning it was supposed to be a
25-minute flight into the city of
Pokhara a popular spot for tourists and
pilgrims but it crashed just seconds
before the flight was expected to land
and as Jennifer Johnson reports in our
top story tonight this is Nepal's worst
airline disaster in three decades
these moments are some of the final
haunting images from inside Yeti
Airlines flight 691 video believed to
have been streamed from on board before
the crash from the ground we see the
plane suddenly banked to the side
recorded by a man on his Terrace the
plane goes into a nosedive and then a
Gorge people rushed to the scene Nepal
calling in its military to speed up the
desperate search
but there were no survivors and little
left of the plane itself Twisted Metal
and burning Rubble the plane was making
a short trip to the new airport in the
tourist town of Pokhara about 200
kilometers outside of Kathmandu
this witness says the plane made a loud
noise before it fell
Nepal's prime minister called the
accident tragic later Gathering his
cabinet to begin its investigation
the twin engine's aircraft's fuselage
split into pieces scattered down terrain
less than two kilometers from the
airport the 68 passengers included 15
foreigners from seven different
countries the aircraft and atr-72 has a
long history of deadly accidents this
aircraft was just 15 years old what I'm
seeing would be consistent with an
aircraft aerodynamic stall with a nose
eye attitude slow speed in which the
left wing loses lift and at Banks left
Nepal is home to eight of the world's 14
highest mountains including Mount
Everest attracting thousands of tourists
each year there have been 42 fatal plane
crashes since 1946 there this is the
deadliest since a Pakistan Airlines
crash in 1992 killing all 167 people
aboard the European Union has banned all
flights from Nepal since 2013 citing
safety concerns it'll be interesting to
get the if the flight data recorder
and the CBR because there will be
information there that will be if they
if they have them and if they've
survived the crash because of the fire
that will be key to the investigation
the weather Sunday was relatively clear
and there were no Hills or mountains on
the path into the airport for Nepal's
Aviation investigators the Grim task of
understanding what happened is just
beginning
Jennifer Johnson Global News Washington
to the war in Ukraine now where the
death tolls mounting from Russia's
latest round of missile strikes over
multiple cities this weekend so far at
least 29 people are confirmed dead
including a child the latest bombardment
hit Ukraine's Southeastern city of nepro
leveling an apartment building on
Saturday and with this grinding War now
and it's an 11th month Ukraine is
calling on its allies to send much
needed support and as Heather York's
West reports some Western allies are
heeding the call
through a frigid January night emergency
workers continued searching for
survivors in new Pro
this woman Katarina was pulled from her
Upper Floor apartment but as the hours
were on the city's mayor fears Crews
will now find more bodies than survivors
I think the chances of saving people now
are minimal he says may God help us find
them
[Music]
after a two-week break in its airstrikes
Russia attacked Saturday across Ukraine
and with vengeance
Russia's defense minister said Sunday
that the strikes allegedly aimed at
military and infrastructure sites in
every Target with no mentions of the
civilians caught in the crosshairs of
the deadly apartment attack where in
addition to the dozens of dead at least
70 others were injured many of them
badly
a nine-year-old girl has been placed in
her Hospital says this official she has
a concussion two broken hips and a
shrapnel injury to her shiny Pro is a
pretty large city in eastern Ukraine and
it's the site where a lot of internally
displaced people have made their second
homes so it's particularly cruel as the
conflict stretches on Putin continues to
Target major pieces of Ukraine's already
battered infrastructure Ukraine says
they need more support in the form of
heavy weapons to win this war the UK is
now promising to send 14 Challenger 2
tanks to the region marking the first
deployment of western-made tanks with
hopes that other allies specifically
Germany will follow suit I think there's
a lot of momentum building across Europe
I saw that at Finland as well is is
discussing sending leopard tanks with
one full year of fighting since the
Russian invasion approaching moscow's
forces are showing signs of fatigue in a
recent interview a senior Russian
official said the country's age limit
for conscription could be expanded as
early as this spring the stakes are only
rising and it seems sadly certain more
people on both sides will die before the
fighting ends Heather urich's West
Global News
in Europe fears that millions of homes
would be left in the cold have not
materialized it's been balmy across the
continent this winter and that means
energy tanks are holding up nicely
Europeans may be breathing a sigh of
relief for now but as kamyar razavi
reports more uncertainty and energy
price swings aren't going anywhere
anytime soon
to say it's been a warm start to the
year in Europe is an understatement in
Malaga in the south of Spain people hit
the beach in January Elsewhere on the
continent ski resorts are bare another
impact a much feared winter of
discontent with millions of homes left
in the cold has not materialized well
they did Dodge bullets obviously they
did gas supplies in Europe are strong
with tanks at about 83 percent full as
of December 31st in Germany fears that
Vladimir Putin would turn off the Taps
has had people conserving energy and the
German government accelerating its
transition to Renewables I think that's
going to change the system from within
within a very short period of time that
transition is happening around the world
and say experts explains a lot of the
volatility in the markets in Europe
natural gas prices were around 340 Euros
per megawatt hour in August they're less
than 70 euros now
more volatility experts say is just
another winter storm political conflict
or all-out War away but it's also a
healthy sign that the world is Shifting
to a different energy reality because if
we were continuing to depend on fossil
fuels to the same extent as we have over
the past few decades you may not see
this much volatility but energy
transitions are not easy it took decades
to go from this to this to this but
that's changing in Alberta Canada's
energy Heartland jobs in the clean
energy sector are set to more than
double over the next decade a sign of
things to come
Global News
just weeks after his re-election Israeli
Prime Minister Benjamin Netanyahu is
facing backlash from thousands major
demonstrations against his reform
policies were held in three cities over
the weekend critics say they proposed
reforms will [ __ ] judicial
Independence Foster corruption and set
back minority rights Netanyahu who is in
his sixth term as prime minister created
a coalition with hard right and Ultra
nationalist parties in order to form his
government his supporters say the
reforms are needed to create a balance
between the executive and judicial
branches UConn's newest Premier Raj
pillai has been officially sworn in as
the territory's 10th premier
paulina's cabinet took the oath of
office during a public ceremony in White
Horse on Saturday he highlighted the
previous work of the current liberal
government while pledging to address
issues related to UConn's rising cost of
living Health Care secure housing and
climate change former liberal leader
Sandy silver stepped down from the
Premiership last fall pillai ran
unopposed in the ensuing leadership race
Canada has lost a Trailblazer and a
champion of disability rights David only
a survivor of childhood polio was the
first newscaster in Canada with a
visible disability he went on to become
the lieutenant governor of Ontario
breaking that same barrier
he's being described tonight as kind
compassionate and gracious the kind of
man who would ask you to drop that your
honor and instead just call him David
but he also had grit tenacious
persistent always pushing everywhere he
went to make Canada a more just place
for those with disabilities Amar Khan
now on his life and his legacy I'm David
only behind me is the new city pulse
from the TV screen to Public Service Mr
Speaker David only spent most of his
life in the public eye after a long and
success-filled career as a reporter and
anchor for City TV a middle-aged woman
was caught shoplifting after she stuffed
a frozen chicken into her bra and
fainted from the cold
he was appointed lieutenant governor of
Ontario in 2007. he hosted the late
Queen Elizabeth when she visited the
province and the Midland native always
did the job with Grace he was determined
to fight for a more inclusive Society
but he was kind and he was gentle and he
was always willing to work with anyone
who was on side only was the 28th
lieutenant governor of Ontario and
became the first ever with a physical
disability caused by polio my dream is
of a province where disability and right
rights are Advanced not only for those
with classically defined physical
disabilities such as mine but also for
those so-called visible disabilities his
advocacy was considered Monumental David
paved the way for many people with
disabilities to believe that they too
could
could act in in roles of leadership his
interwoven Paths of Journalism and being
a Mainstay at Queen's Park led him to be
admired by many after the broadcasting
portion of his career what struck me
about getting to know him just a little
bit by covering him at Queen's Park was
his his warmth and his sense of humor a
very very quick wit with a deep and
burgeoning Legacy in life nothing was
more outstanding than onley's character
to those who knew him he did it with so
much dignity and so much grace he's
inspired many people including myself
to follow in his path flags are at half
mast to honor the former Lieutenant
Governor David only is survived by his
wife ruthanne and three sons he was 72.
Amar Khan Global News
[Music]
you heard former Ontario Premier
Kathleen Nguyen and amar's Report we're
going to speak with her about what
fueled David only's advocacy
that conversation coming up in 10
minutes
[Music]
in the U.S Californians are enduring
more heavy rains and dangerous flooding
as yet another storm wreaks havoc on
their state
rescue crews had to airlift this woman
to safety Saturday after she was left
hanging onto a tree trapped by Rising
Waters President Joe Biden has also made
an emergency declaration to send
California federal aid over the almost
non-stop barrage of atmospheric Rivers
for about three weeks now the weather
has battered the Golden State with
floods mudslides power outages and has
been responsible for at least 19 deaths
in Nova Scotia significant rainfall was
also the source of flooding in
schumannacity about 60 kilometers north
of Halifax
the road is passable now but a detour
route was set in place on Saturday
because of high water it's deemed high
risk for flooding because of its
proximity to the schumannacity river
where residents say culverts meant to
drain water out of the area are the main
concern because they've collapsed on
more than one occasion three walls of
our house was literally underwater under
the basement it was up to the basement
windows and it was just pouring into our
basement like a faucet we shouldn't have
to go through it every couple months
in a statement the Department of Public
Works acknowledged that the issue is
with a damaged Culvert and says given
that the issue is on private property
they will work with the local
municipality and private property owners
to find a solution
Montreal could soon play host for at
least one NFL game
the NFL is looking to expand its
footprint outside the U.S and
administrators of Olympic Park have
confirmed they're in talks with the NFL
to bring the League's International
series to Montreal the city's Olympic
Stadium recently got a brand new 700 000
artificial field and last week it was
certified as a FIFA quality professional
playing service the last time the NFL
was in Montreal was for a preseason game
between the New York Jets and Cleveland
Browns back in 1990.
Mass solidarity ahead remembering the
victims still missing from a Quebec fire
and explosion
a solidarity Mass took place this
morning in San Rock de la chigan a town
about 45 minutes north of Montreal where
three people are still missing following
a fire and explosion at a propane
Distribution Company Elizabeth zagalis
reports
foreign
it was a Sunday mass for everyone we
need
to be together we need to pray
no matter what what is the fate of the
people several hundred residents from
Saint and its neighboring towns filled
the pews at a local church in a certain
way I'm happy to see that there were so
many people here in the church
to express their presence solidarity for
people who are mourning three employees
of a propane Distribution Company are
still missing after an explosion and
fire that level the building last
Thursday the families of the other
missing persons don't have news right
now
Sebastian Marcel says the hardest part
for loved ones is waiting for answers
completely shocked completely
completely sad about about what's
happening and
and uh and we're getting through this as
a village it's a town where everyone
knows each other
these are people I knew since my
childhood says this man I went to school
with them so for us it hits close to
home Quebec Provincial Police have not
yet established a cause for the
explosion they say the weather and
condition of the site has also made it
difficult to locate the missing
employees Quebec told us that they would
be like many days uh be before they they
will leave the site because of the all
the complexity of the the explosion
unfortunately there isn't much families
and residents can do while they wait for
answers but Marcel hopes they can find
some comfort in having a close Community
for support One Step at the time
foreign
[Music]
next the legacy of a Trailblazer we
speak with former Ontario Premier
Kathleen Nguyen who served with late
Lieutenant Governor David only
[Music]
as we told you earlier in the newscast
David only a Toronto TV reporter who
became Ontario's lieutenant governor
passed away last night at the age of 72.
only broke barriers many people thought
couldn't be bent his fight for
disability Justice changed perspectives
and changed lives and to those who knew
him he remained kind generous and
genuine the entire way joining us now is
someone who worked with him for a long
time Kathleen Nguyen she served as
Ontario Premier for much of onley's term
thank you so much for joining us what do
you remember the most about David only
I think my um my Everlasting impression
and memory of David only is going to be
his compassion and his determination you
know he was determined to be an activist
for people with disabilities he was
determined to fight for a more inclusive
Society but he was kind and he was
gentle and he was always willing to work
with anyone who was on side you know he
wasn't partisan he just wanted he wanted
to get the work done and that that was
how I knew him when I first met him in
the late 90s and that was how I knew him
when I was premier
I was very fortunate to work with him at
the beginning of my career he was
passionate and driven but incredibly
humble are there any memories that
you're thinking about tonight Ms win
I remember being at a downtown Toronto
school so I was a parent activist it was
in the late 90s and I was fired up about
what was going on in uh in government at
that point and David was a reporter and
I remember being in a school that was
really inaccessible and he was very
agitated you know he was very clear and
he kind of went out of that journalist
neutral character and was talking to us
about how how unjust our built
um environment was and that was my first
that was my first sort of window on that
determination that he he brought to
everything that he did I didn't know him
I knew him as a reporter but but I saw
the man in that moment where he was just
saying you know this is ridiculous can't
get into these schools he shows up at
buildings and he can't get in and um and
that you know that anger I think fueled
the the activist work that he did when
he was advising Dalton McGinty and then
when he was advising me and then when
and when he was lieutenant governor and
he would travel around the province and
he made it clear everywhere he went that
we all had to do more in order to in
include children and adults in our
society
what Legacy does he leave behind for
Ontario and for Canada
I think he leaves a legacy of
um of determined activism and he rose to
the highest office in the province and
he did it with Grace and he showed what
what anyone can do no matter what their
uh no matter what their ability on I
think that I think that was a very proud
thing for him that he was able to travel
in all of these circles from being a
journalist from being a
um an activist to uh to being the
lieutenant governor of the province and
he used that platform and I think that
the The Province and the country have
been changed because of his
determination and his his modeling of
that courage
Kathleen Nguyen thank you so much for
joining us and for sharing your memories
tonight it was an honor thank you
and that's global national for this
Sunday night I'm Farah Nasser there will
no doubt be many tributes ahead for
David only and he'll be sorely missed by
friends in broadcasting and politics
right across Canada
we leave you tonight with the flags at
half mast in Queens Park and City Hall
in Toronto today in honor of Ontario's
late lieutenant governor and champion of
disability rights on behalf of our whole
crew I want to thank you for spending
part of your evening with us Donna we'll
be back with you tomorrow until next
time take care of yourselves and each
other have a good night
[Music]
foreign